most visitors to derry/londonderry come
for its lively cultural scene and
historical architecture
but the city in northern ireland also
offers some mouth-watering options for
gourmets for instance browns the
restaurant is considered one of the
finest on the island owner and head chef
Ian or opened Braun's restaurant in 2009
and rapidly established itself as a
culinary highlight thanks to one simple
idea we try to be as local and seasonal
as we can with definite seasonal which
are the use as much political produce as
we can but our our ethos is very simple
food but cooked to perfection
derry/londonderry lies just a few
kilometers from the Atlantic coast man
the local cuisine is rich in fish
recipes Ian or gets his fish straight
from a local merchant who fillets it
on-site
the chef himself has two main rules when
he's shopping for fish sometimes we get
fest agressor comes up in Phillips right
so we haven't seen it when its halt but
obviously the best way as the check
that's firm and also there's no smell
Yura max is treated to a platter of hake
and place with summer vegetables and
this is how you nor does it with salt
and pepper
lettuce arts and tarragon butter and
Perl onions and some peas with a bit of
fried bacon first he sprinkles the fish
fillets with salt and pepper before
adding some oil to a pan and frying the
larger piece the egg first has to be hot
not smoking hot but that's you know you
hear that noise straightaway and
secondly room temperature makes a big
difference if you cook an antique
Fischer meats have a room temperature
because if a it cooks quicker or more
evenly a place only needs a quick fry
before it's ready
then both fillets are placed in the oven
for five minutes
Braun's restaurant has received numerous
awards ironically it was only a plan B
for its owner Ian nor he actually wanted
to do something completely different
well I wanted to be a fireman but my
father my father's a fire officer but
I'm colorblind so I couldn't become a
fireman and I decided to become a chef I
started off on a real local chip shop
serving burgers and fish and chips and
that's where I got the passion and ever
since we just you know we have to be
passionate what you're doing for if
you're cooking a burger to cook a
beautiful place that has to be you know
if you have the possible all these young
Chefs they absolutely for them for the
summer vegetables Ian or blend some
butter with chicken stock then he adds
the pearl onions and peas and brings it
briefly to a boil
last up he adds strips of lettuce hearts
and tarragon to the pot so you don't
want to kind of cook it too much it
looks absolutely amazing
tastes even better let's just a bleep
here
take place and veggies a classic dish at
Brown's restaurant in Derry Londonderry
in Northwest Northern Ireland